well in the immortal words of the Robot
Chicken version of M night Shyamalan
what a twist
[Applause]
[Music]
glass yeah I really wasn't sure what to
expect coming into this one I've been
avoiding trailers
I'm sorry not trailers I've been
avoiding her I've been avoiding reviews
like I didn't look at the Rotten
Tomatoes core you know reviewers who I
normally follow I saw they have reviews
out I didn't watch them or read them um
I did pick up the general whiff of a
very divided leaning negative response
people didn't seem to love it
so I didn't know what to expect going in
I liked unbreakable a lot but I haven't
revisited it in a long time and I liked
split
quite a bit um but I mean if there's
anyone who has a history of completely
obliterating the their potential and
nose-diving into ideas that just were
never gonna work it's animated Shyamalan
so this really could have gone any way
and I kind of went in very nervous and
came out quite liking it um now that
being said I get why a lot of people
don't why a lot people get thrown off by
it and having now like consumed some of
the reviews that I've been putting off a
lot of hang-ups seems to be on the
ending and I will get to that but that's
spoilers so we'll circle back to it the
first thing is this I would say it does
match the description of an M night
Shyamalan version of a superhero movie
but you need to really realize the
emphasis is on the M night Shyamalan
this is his approach this is his pacing
this is his characters in a superhero
kind of setting anyone who went in
expecting something feeling more like
what superhero movies are standardly
today just is not gonna get it at all um
it helps to have a pretty decent working
knowledge of both unbreakable and split
I think split probably a little bit more
because like I said I haven't revisited
unbreakable in a long time but I
remembered it well enough to catch
everything that was going on there
with split it gets a little bit more
into the nitty gritty the core
performances are all really good which
is a big saving grace because what can
sink an M night Shyamalan movie a fair
number of the time is the casting and
not that he casts people who can't act
it's just that he writes very stilted
dialogue he does not write natural
sounding speech and some actors can work
with that
some can't and you know when he gets
actors who can actually work with the
kinds of things he tends to write in the
way he tends to write them you know you
get things like The Sixth Sense like
split like I'm breakable like signs um
but when he gets actors who don't know
what to do with these kinds of
characters in these kind of words you
get things like the village and the
happening and it can be be be really
painful thankfully I mean the the core
the main three characters are all
returning from good Shum Ilan movies so
they all know what they're doing
but even beyond that everyone else is
quite good as well means there'll
Paulson I've never seen her give a bad
performance so that helps and actually I
was quite surprised how much I ended up
liking I I don't know the actor's name
but the guy who played Bruce Willis's
kid in unbreakable is back playing that
role again now as an adult he's quite
good it's something about his he's got
very dark eyes is something oddly
compelling about that um I think
ultimately MVP performance wise is gonna
be James McAvoy because much like in
split he's got the showiest part and he
gets to show off his acting a lot more
than that anyone else does and
he kind of revels in that um but Bruce
Willis is Bruce Willis is awake for this
that's not always a guarantee these days
but ya know he's he's giving a
performance of the caliber that he gave
the last time so he's on point and I
mean Samuel Jackson oh man he he does
great work so structurally the film is a
bit weird so it opens what with what
feels like it could be the start to a
more conventional clash of hero and
villain type film the middle section
where and this I don't consider spoiler
because it was clear from other trailers
where Elijah price that's a Samuel
Jackson's character David Dunn that's
Bruce Willis and Kevin or the Horde
I'll probably just column which is James
McAvoy's characters are all in a
psychiatric facility being treated by
Sarah Paulson who is trying to cure them
of the delusion that they have
superhuman abilities and that is sort of
the longest stretch and it is slow but
it's slow in the way that anyone who
knows em night Shyamalan movie should
expect an M night Shyamalan movie to be
slow you know its its pacing certainly
comparable to unbreakable so and I quite
enjoyed that I liked the interactions a
lot I liked the there I felt it was a
sense of tension throughout that whole
section that worked quite well and then
the third act the third act is
undoubtedly the weirdest cuz what is
going on in the third act is very
strange
Shyamalan blatantly sets something up
and then very deliberately does not
deliver it so that's the first thing we
so we're dealing with to a certain
degree deliberate disappointment which
is always a difficult thing to juggle so
he's got that at play he has got I well
I was gonna say a pair of twists I would
actually argue three twists that are
kind of stacked up back to back to back
and admittedly the second one of those
twists which is like the big one came
very close to losing me
the third one kind of softened the blow
of the second and it gave the film a
finishing note that I was actually quite
happy with but yeah there is there is
that second twist man it's it's a doozy
and I don't necessarily mean like you'll
never see it coming but you you will
never see it coming but like in a wave
kind of way um but I'll get into that in
a little more detail when I started
talking spoilers but ultimately I'm okay
with the ending
um I don't love it it's probably the
weakest section of the movie and if
somebody's gonna be your weakest part
the ending that's not a good place to
have your weakest bit that said I don't
hate it I'm pretty okay with it all
things considered and I feel like in
many ways the very final note of it kind
of saves it as a whole from where I was
afraid it was gonna leave me feeling by
the end so I think I think I'm gonna
start getting into spoilers short
version I actually quite liked it it's
hard for me to recommend because I feel
like I'd like I said I can see why this
didn't work for a lot of people the end
especially um but I still liked it and I
even do like the in it I don't love the
ending but I do like it so I'm gonna get
into spoilers now okay so I mentioned
three twists twists one I loved which is
that we we delve a little bit more into
the Horde Kevin's history is sort of the
traumatic events that caused his split
and the the formation
multiple personalities and one of the
major contributing factors was his
father left and that left him unguarded
with his very abusive mother well the
first twist that we find out is that
Kevin had always thought and had been
operating on the assumption that his dad
just bailed he just got on a train one
day and didn't come back
well that wasn't just any train that was
the train that Elijah price derailed at
the start of unbreakable the same train
accident that spawned david dunn and
sort of initiated his realization of his
powers so that's twist one which I like
a lot
then there's twist two twist two is the
is the apparent existence of a mole
multiple millennia-old
secret society that exists to keep
people with superhuman abilities from
being revealed either by convincing them
that they are just delusional
or by killing them if necessary and
first of all that that very concept is
that's bonkers and and it feels it feels
like the biggest leap that this thing
could take cuz if you remember the other
films unbreakable was pretty dang
grounded it was I mean that was kind of
its pitch it was a very realistic world
split was not as grounded but wasn't
this off the rails this so this is
asking a really big leap of the audience
especially relative to what kind of had
been stabbed established as how real is
this world so that's that's one thing
that's going on here
but then in addition to that part of
what goes on there is they do kill the
Horde and they do kill David Dunn which
that
was where I was starting to go like wait
what what what like and I was like wait
a minute wait a minute wait a minute but
there's then the third twist which is
that basically Elijah price mr. glass
knew the whole time that he and the
other two were not gonna survive this
whole thing and he had arranged for the
multiple security cameras recording
everything going on in and outside the
mental facility to be streamed and then
to be and then to go out to people who
would then upload it for the general
public
in other words reveal that what humans
had been told as the limit of human
possibility is not people can achieve
more and be more and ending it on that
note as opposed to just ending it on
there's a secret society note it worked
for me
there's something about the odd kind of
hopefulness of yeah but now the secret's
out and the the world knows and who
knows what happens next and there's sort
of that air of possibility to it that
for me did a lot to kind of take the
curse of the insanity of the other
secret society twist
yeah and that that's just kind of how it
played out for me by the end first twist
loved it second twist wait what and then
third twist okay yeah no I'm good now
and I don't know how reflective that is
of anybody else's experience watching it
but I could definitely see plenty of
people where that second twist that
reveal the secret society just makes
people go that's it I'm out and I
wouldn't even blame them for that it's
kind of a dumb idea but the way it pans
out ultimately I'm
with it I'm satisfied with it I actually
quite like this movie
so yeah glass have you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do because there's buttons
and links there's one to the patreon I
just restructured the the reward tiers
if you want to check it out if you
haven't been there in a while and seen
what's what plus I got a pedo box
other links besides check out any or all
of them if you want or if you don't that
is okay too because at the end of the
day you are the council
I'm just running the meanings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]